Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and yesterday
in my City of Blood video I asked you all
to submit your biggest questions about the
episode and the rest of the season.
So we’re going to answer 10 of them with
one bonus question.
There’s only two more episodes left in season
2 and the Starling City weather service is
predicting fire tornadoes with a heavy chance
of Apocalypse..
If you’re finding me for the first time
every week I do Q&A videos like this for fun
stuff just so I can feature questions you
guys leave me that I think are really interesting.
It’s also fun to follow up on WTF stuff
that happens during the week.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything.
I’ve even got some Spider-Man stuff coming
tomorrow!
So time for questions, careful for spoilers
from episode 21 if you haven’t seen it yet.
Here we go.
Question 1 - SvenTuSventu asks What do you
think Oliver will call the new Foundry?
I’m expecting that he’ll call it the Arrowcave
in a twist of his reaction to Felicity back
when Roy joined.
He was all like “we do not call it that”.
I’d really like for him to have a moment
where he caves, sorry for the word play, and
just calls it the new Arrowcave.
The thing about the show is that Oliver is
always the straight man, that’s a comedy
term.
In a comedy sketch where you have two or more
people.
You’ll have one person who’s not in on
the joke and they’ll just react to the other
people being silly.
Saturday Night Live does it all the time.
On Arrow, that’s Oliver, Felicity is the
goofy one and we always see Oliver frown at
her when he doesn’t like her jokes.
So when they let Oliver be silly on very very
rare occassions, it ends up being that much
funnier.
Because he’s always so serious.
Thus, I want him to call it the new Arrowcave.
At least once.
Question 2 - Kofi asks do you think Merlyn
will take Thea under his wing and save her?
He’ll definitely rescue her but I don’t
think Willa Holland is leaving the show, so
she probably won’t go with him.
In order to get that Merlyn Thea Artemis storyline,
she’d have to go away, because John Barrowman
isn’t coming back to the show full time.
So you’d have to have Willa leave the show
in the way Barry Allen left the show to go
back to Central City.
I think Thea will still be a full time cast
member in season 3, so she’s probably going
to not go with him.
That doesn’t mean Merlyn is going to die
or not come back in season 3.
Characters are way more fun when they’re
haunted by evil parents.
And now that Moira is gone, Merlyn is going
to fill that role.
I expect him to pop in at least once or twice
next season.
Or at least be referenced in conversation.
Laurel talks about Tommy with Oliver, so of
course Thea is going to talk to Oliver about
her father.
Question 3 - Austin (no avatar) asks Do you
think Nyssa will die in the finale and that
will cause Ra’s Al Ghul to unleash on Starling
City?
No, I think that Katrina Law is too precious
of an actor for them to get rid of her character.
She’s the best representation of the League,
Ra’s and Talia that they could get without
having to deal with complicated continuity
issues.
That’s why you don’t see more characters
jumping from show to show.
Even Marvel only does it a little.
So anytime they want to use the League as
a story device, they can bring her back.
As for her relationship with Oliver and the
city, we’ll have to wait and see.
But she treats Oliver the way you’d treat
anyone who’s dating your ex.
With a little bit of contempt.
But I think she accepts what he represents,
so they’re not enemies.
More like frenemies.
I do like the idea of Oliver creating his
own villains.
That’s kind of what happened with Huntress
and Slade to a certain degree, although she
wasn’t really his enemy.
Slade you could say is more of an enemy of
circumstance.
The only reason he’s doing this is because
of the mirakuru, so once they cure him.
His entire motivation will be gone.
I think that there will be a new villain at
some point that Oliver will be directly responsible
for creating.
Remember the Michael Keaton Batman and his
relationship to the Jack Nicholson Joker.
Joker shoots parents, Batman dumps Joker in
vat of chemicals.
I think Oliver will get a moment like that
eventually.
Maybe not next season, but before the series
is over.
I suppose you could argue that’s what’s
been going on this season, but Slade didn’t
strand Oliver on the Island.
Question 4 - Oliver Queen asks do you think
Brother Blood will have a change of heart
before the finale?
When Oliver made him face facts about Slade
there was a moment of hesitation on his face.
But I think he’s committed himself to the
cause, he’s basically drinking his own mirakuru
kool aide.
Remember that shot of Laurel with the bow
from next week’s episode?
I think she’s going to have the pleasure
of killing him.
I don’t really care how she does it, but
if she did kill him with the bow.
It would be pretty freaking sweet.
I think if any of the villains will die this
season, he’s the one.
Laurel has gone pretty dark, wiretapping him
without a warrant, breaking the law, using
extortion to get her job back.
I totally think she’s going to kill him
to save Oliver and the rest of Team Arrow.
Question 5 - Sour Rooster asks if Sara dies,
do you think that Nyssa could become the Season
3 villain?
No, but if Sara does end up dying I think
she’ll flip out and kill a bunch of soldiers.
I don’t think she’d hold Sara’s death
against Oliver.
She wouldn’t waste her time on him.
The League is from Nanda Parbat, but they’re
an international organization with operations
going on all over the planet.
So Starling City is a spec of dust in their
grand design.
I would like to see her fight Slade.
She and Oliver were basically an even match,
so she’d do at least as good against Slade
as Oliver has done.
I guess that doesn’t say much, because Oliver
has gotten the crap kicked out of him every
time he’s fought Slade in close quarters.
Question 6 - Matchoman asks Did you see that
T statue in Brother Blood's Office?
How soon could a Teen Titans spinoff occur
and who would be a villain for them to handle?﻿
Right now they’re still trying to get The
Flash show ordered to series.
We’ll know in about two weeks if that’s
going to happen.
By the middle of May.
There’s like a 99 percent chance that’s
going to happen based on news from inside
the CW.
If The Flash TV Show ends up being really
successful they’ll start targeting new shows
to develop.
Right now I think there’s a better chance
of a Suicide Squad show happening before anything
else.
Just because they’ve spent a lot of time
developing those characters from the villains
on the team, to Amanda Waller who’s like
the main character.
In order for them to do Teen Titans they have
to fully develop a protagonist like Roy.
Then at least two other team members like
Sin and Thea.
And those people would have to leave Arrow.
So I don’t think Arrow is going to let go
of Willa Holland or Colton Haynes anytime
soon.
So no Teen Titans for the foreseeable future.
Question 7 - Pastor Will asks What do you
think he meant when Oliver say that they started
with just those three and they needed to get
back to that?
I think he was talking more about the finale.
I think they’ll end up with the three of
them versus Slade.
I don’t think Ravager or Brother Blood will
be in the final fight.
Question 8 - Eric Jaffa (no avatar) asks Who
do you think Isabel Rochev’s hallucinating
since she’s full of mirakuru now too?
Good question, usually the person everyone
hallucinates is someone they had a sexual
relationship with.
Or in Slade’s situation, a person they had
sexual feelings for.
But in her case, I think she’s hallucinating
Diggle, just because he’s the one that visited
her trauma on her.
As in killed her.
And it seems like her main goal right now
is to get revenge for that.
I think both she and Brother Blood have what
they want, they got what Slade promised them.
So at this point, they’re just along for
the ride.
It’s like they won the lottery and now they’re
just trying to figure out what to spend all
the cash on.
Question 9 - Jerry Chan asks do you think
Laurel could become Artemis instead of Black
Canary?
I totally think that’s a possibility but
I think that’s a whole new character arc
that would have to wait till season 3.
She’s definitely going to be a more active
member of team Arrow in season 3, but I think
most of her time will be spent in a support
role like Felicity.
She’ll probably train just because she seems
less physically awkward than Felicity but
she’ll never be as vicious as Sara.
So what I’m hoping is that Sara will survive
the finale and just go back to the League
with Nyssa, but she’ll help Oliver train
her.
We just won’t see a lot of that on screen.
But I do expect Oliver to have some bow training
scenes with Laurel next year.
I definitely think Team Arrow needs more girl
power to balance out all the dudes.
It’s a bit of a sausage fest right now.
And as much as Felicity is Oliver’s conscience,
Laurel is more of an equal.
Not so much in a physical sense, but in that
she wields as much authority as a character.
Question 10 - Jonah asks Do you think the
Suicide Squad will help deal with the Mirakuru
army?
Yes, there’s no way they’re going to be
able to subdue all those super soldiers by
themselves.
That image we say of Nyssa in the finale implies
that the League won’t be back until that
episode.
Which means Oliver is going to have to get
more help next week.
Bonus Question - JY9012 asks Is Roy coming
back in the next episode and will he be cured?
Frankenstein has to wake up at some point.
They certainly teased it enough this week.
I think that once they have the cure they’ll
fix Roy first and then figure out how to deliver
the cure to the rest of the super soldiers.
I know a lot of you have also been asking
about Roy’s Arsenal costume.
Stephen Amell did say that there would be
one more costume featured this year.
Based on recent developments I think he was
talking about Ravager.
In order for Roy to get a suit, Oliver would
have to make it.
And right now he’s underneath a pile of
concrete trapped with a bunch of super soldiers.
So he’s not going to be able to sew any
red leather pants for a long time.
So thanks so much for submitting your questions.
These are always a ton of fun to do.
Like I said, there’s only two more episodes
left.
Be sure to subscribe to get my videos.
I’ll post my next Arrow bonus video wednesday
before episode 22 airs.
Feel free to leave me suggestions for what
that should be about.
Right now click here to for my review of the
episode and click here to learn more about
the Justice League Movie.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow.
High Fives!